Riding High بعد هبوطها الناعم الناجح
على سطح القمر،
أصدرت وكالة الفضاء الهندية مقطع فيديو
لمركبتها Lunarova وهي تبدأ مهمتها
لاستكشاف القطب الجنوبي للقمر
Uncharted Territory
الهند هي أول دولة لديها
مسارات على الأرض هناك على الرغم من أن
دولًا أخرى مثل الولايات المتحدة
قام الاتحاد السوفييتي السابق والصين
بهبوط محكم على أجزاء أخرى
من سطح القمر في
جولة النصر في
منظمة أبحاث الفضاء الهندية. وقال رئيس الوزراء الهندي
ناريندرا مودي إن هذا
إنجاز علمي تاريخي يضع
الهند في طليعة
استكشاف هذا الفضاء الاستراتيجي.  الجزء من
القمر الذي يقول العلماء إنه يمكن أن
يحتوي على خصائص تحافظ على الحياة مثل
رواسب المياه المجمدة في حفره الغامضة،
المنطقة التي ستستكشفها مهمتنا
ستساعد في فتح آفاق جديدة لمهمات القمر
من قبل بلدان أخرى،
وهذا لن يكشف فقط أسرار
القمر.  القمر ولكنها تساعد أيضًا في حل
تحديات الأرض.
فشلت محاولة روسية للهبوط الناعم على القطب الجنوبي للقمر منذ حوالي
أسبوع.
وتخطط الولايات المتحدة للقيام بمهمة أولية للهبوط
في المنطقة في أواخر عام 2025 أو 2026.
وستقوم اليابان قريبًا  إطلاق مركبة هبوط على سطح القمر
إلى الفضاء على الرغم من أنها لن تسافر إلى
القطب الجنوبي للقمر، حيث
يهدف جهاز الهبوط المسمى سليم والمعروف أيضًا باسم قناص القمر إلى القيام بهبوط دقيق
على سطح القمر جنوب
بحر الهدوء، ومن المخطط أن يكون
اختبار عالي الدقة لمعرفة ما إذا كانت
المركبة الفضائية يمكنها الهبوط على بعد مائة
متر من هدفها وبينما
قد يعود القمر إلى دائرة الضوء فإن
أعمال استكشاف الفضاء مستمرة
على جبهات أخرى
تستعد محطة الفضاء الدولية لاستقبال طاقم جديد مكون من أربعة
أفراد  انطلقت
الولايات المتحدة واليابان وروسيا والدنمارك من أربع دول مختلفة
يوم السبت لبدء
مهمتها التي تستغرق ستة أشهر في محطة الفضاء الدولية